on va parler d'immobilier maintenant
préoccupation très importante
des canadiens en ce moment et on a des
données importantes aujourd'hui la
chambre immobilière de toronto estime
que la forte baisse
que la forte baisse du nombre de
propriétés à vendre est alarmante le
nombre de nouvelles inscriptions a chuté
de 43% en nous par rapport à l'an
dernier le nombre de transactions a
baissé aussi de 20% alors déséquilibre
entre l'offre et la demande ce qui fait
pression sur les prix le prix moyen qui
dépasse le million de dollars en hausse
de 13% puis on est dans la même
dynamique qu'à vancouver inscriptions en
baisse de 31% en nous le nombre de
transactions a grimpé un peu 3,4 pour
cent et le prix a augmenté de 13% 1
million 176 1600 dollars on n'a pas ce
soir avec denis du sec et porte parole
du cabinet hypothécaire multi-prêts
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur clients
messieurs tout ce qu'est ce qui se passe
à toronto pour qu'on assiste à une si
forte baisse des inscriptions de
propriétés à vendre je pense que vous
avez mentionné le fait qu'ils aient peu
de maisons à vendre
évidemment ça crée une pression à la
hausse sur les prix des gens mettent
leur maison que plusieurs acheteurs
c'est c'est un phénomène qui était déjà
apparue ap toronto il ya plusieurs
années je crois des années 90 par la
suite bon il y avait eu baisse de prix
sur tous vos livres des propriétés plus
cher puis là on semble s'en retourner
dans un phénomène à peu près semblable
mais même chez nous on voit ça fait des
années qu'on voit l'offre qui n'est pas
au rendez vous il manque de construction
il manque de construction c'est sur les
je pense que dd des prévisions qui l'ont
fait ont peut-être négligé la croissance
de la population qu'on a eu
un peu partout au pays puis incluant le
québec si ça fait qu'il ya déjà
plusieurs personnes qui voudraient
acheter mais dès la disponibilité de
propriété puis depuis le début de la
pandémie on a vu d'ailleurs d'etel mars
2020 plusieurs personnes ont retiré leur
inscription du marché puis sont parvenus
encore la chambre immobilière parle d'un
marché qui est alarmant en ce moment
parce que parce que quoi on pourrait
assister à une nouvelle poussée des prix
sont déjà très élevés
évidemment si peu d'offres dès que les
gens veulent acheter il va arriver à
avoir une surenchère qui va se produire
comme ça se produit le depuis un an même
au québec on a vu plusieurs endroits où
il y avait de la surenchère plusieurs
offres d'achat dans des délais
extrêmement courts ça procès ça provoque
des hausses de prix puis le peu d'offres
une des raisons c'est que les gens
actuellement se rendre compte que c'est
difficile de se trouver une maison à un
prix raisonnable
donc avant de mettre sa maison à vendre
pour en racheter une autre
licence deux fois
effectivement c'est le bon calcul à
faire de toute façon et quand on regarde
toronto centre on voit des difficultés
importantes parce que les prix montent
les jeunes ménages là malgré des bons
salaires peut-être à toronto peine à se
trouver une maison c'est trop cher
quelles sont les conséquences de tout ça
ce qu'on a vu qu'il toronto le vécu
montréal le véhicule s'est en partie
cycle et des gens s'éloignent qui est
particulièrement avec la girelle à la
hausse importante du télétravail qui est
survenu depuis un an et demi
les gens se sont éloignés parce que le
prix ils demandent qu'en comptant de
prix moyen ça tient pas compte non plus
des différents secteurs même sur l'île
de montréal seront comparées laisse de
l'est de l'ouest de l'île déjà on a des
différences de prix importantes puis que
des convois dans la première ou la
deuxième couronne de montréal ou un peu
à québec l'extérieur de québec on se
retrouve avec des maisons des prix qui
sont peut-être plus accessible surtout
que les premiers acheteurs alors il ya
tout un enjeu d'accès à la propriété en
ce moment qu'est ce que vous pensez des
propositions présentées par les
différents partis politiques depuis le
début de la campagne électorale
y a des idées c'est sûr que ce que les
libéraux ont proposé dans un espèce de
ces 10 pour qui serait pas imposé à moi
au niveau du bénéfice dont on sait que
l'investissement comme sur ses lots
composés qui est intéressant quand on
est sur une longue période mais je crois
pas que les gens l'économiste en 15 ou
20 ans pour s'acheter une maison par
contre si il me dit tiens un petit peu
son plein pour le rendre déductibles
d'impôt et non remboursables à ce moment
là c'est sûr que ça deviendrait
peut-être intéressant pour les gens de
pouvoir accumuler un peu plus de mise de
fonds parce que comprendre quand les
prix augmentent la mise de fonds
augmente aussi des gens ont des
difficultés à les ramasser du côté du
npd le 20% qu'ils veulent à cliquer sur
les étrangers qui n'habite pas au canada
c'est pas une mauvaise idée par contre
c'est petit pour ce qui va permettre
être des premiers acheteurs d'acheter
une propriété
c'est peut-être dans les propriétés un
peu plus haut de gamme le que le ça
pourrait peut-être assainir un peu là
les hausses de prix ce qu'ils ont à
faire aussi dans l'est des conservateurs
avaient une approche qui
s'y posent l'école n'est pas une
approche qui aide les gens les premiers
acheteurs surtout à acheter une
propriété
c'est des choses qui bon le
politiquement parlant peuvent peut-être
donné certains votes mais ça ça
permettra aux concurrents de la
situation qui l'a particulièrement au
québec le lait avec les sens là que les
gens font c'est assez difficile
d'accumuler d'argent et de pouvoir se
qualifier aussi parce que on parle de
nous on donne déjà de toute
qualification qui ne met de gouvernement
a décidé depuis juin dernier à 5.25 pour
cinq ans qu'on calcule pourrait donc
indépendant même si les prêts sont air
un point quelque chose il reste qu'il
faut qualifier la personne à 5.25 et ça
ça n'a pas changé puis malgré toutes les
mesures qui mettent en place ça change
repos je veux dire que la capacité
d'emport pour pas nécessairement
augmenter ça va être la même chose taxis
des prix augmente de kbc d'emprunt à
gbagbo on a un sérieux problème pour la
mise de fonds absolument je mentionne
que les données pour montréal seront
publiés hardy nous allons en parler 2012
c'est merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous jacques lizé aura alors pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit